the lgbtqi2 Spirit Plus now is
resembling more of an unbreakable Wi-Fi
code than it is anything that is that
speaks to a same-sex attracted people
which is of course what we should be
talking about we have something in
common even though one side of men and
one-sided women
the gender wurus that have come in are
absolutely Bonkers and you're right that
they target women they target lesbians
in particular they target women because
if you think about the clever ruse of
trans activism what it's done is it's
positioned me as they would say a CIS
woman as the oppressor of a trans woman
so therefore the oppressor class the
privileged class whether you believe in
patriarchy or not whether you think
women are oppressed we all know that
there's a disadvantage that women face
in life compared to like men and
we are now the oppressor of men who
identify as women